for a couple of months now the Middle
East has once again been in turmoil the
conflict between Israel and Palestine or
rather with Hamas has once again made
the front pages of the international
press the world is on alert and the
major powers are even more so US
military deployment to prevent the
spread of conflict in the Middle East
2,000 troops two aircraft carriers and
135 fighter jets China stationed up to
six warships in Middle East amid Rising
tensions from Israel Gaza War Iran's
foreign minister warns Israel from
Beirut to stop Gaza attacks or risk huge
earthquake but since the beginning of
the conflict doesn't it seem to you that
there is one missing piece in this
complex puzzle what is happening with
the biggest Arab power in the Middle
East what is happening with Saudi Arabia
visual politic viewers the Saudi regime
is in a particularly delicate position
on the one hand this conflict is
particularly bad news for its economic
growth plans including its geopolitical
and strategic interests the tension
right now is bad for all that what's
more the shadow of Iran lurks in the
region and Saudi Arabia is very clear if
Hamas wins Iran wins as a consequence
many analysts are already raising the
possibility that Saudi Arabia is eagerly
hoping for a quick victory in Israel in
this conflict although I can't say it
outright everything indicates that this
is exactly the case but what economic
interests does the Saudi regime have to
cause them to want Hamas is defeat why
would a Hamas Victory be a victory for
Iran could hamas's success escalate the
conflict between the Saudis and the
houthis in Yemen well in this video we
will answer these and other questions
let's fire up the engines and let's get
started negotiation on
[Music]
standby just a couple of weeks before
Hamas attacked Israel on the 7th of
October 2023 Saudi Arabia and Israel
were moving quickly to finalize the
agreement that would normalize their
political and economic relations once
and for all an agreement promoted by the
Biden Administration 3 years after the
famous Abraham Accords brought Israel to
shake hands with several Arab Nations
but that was only the beginning by far
the most pursued by Washington and also
Above All by prime minister Netanyahu
was to reach the agreement with Riyad
for its part the Arab country was also
eager to reap both the economic and
Military benefits that the UAE is
already getting since the signing of the
Abraham agreements what benefits
basically access to the prosperous and
advanced Israeli economy and above all
Israeli technology naturally besides all
that to achieving the much desired and
necessary Regional stability and all
this is happening at a time when Saudi
Arabia is particularly crazy about
diversifying its economy keep in mind
that for the moment its main economic
livelihood is still oil exports
therefore in an attempt to overcome this
dependence once and for all the largest
Arab power is promoting a series of Mega
projects through its Vision 2030
strategy basically a sort of Mission
Impossible desert Edition because visual
politic Community we are talking about
true Mega projects which I'm sure you
have all heard about the line The
Surreal desert city already under
construction in Saudi Arabia neon to see
world's largest floating industrial
complex oag with these projects Saudi
Arabia aims to make its economy less
vulnerable yet in order to build them
and succeed the regime is clear it needs
stability in the
region the agreement it had been
negotiating with Israel and the United
States was crucial to achieving this
goal even so no matter how far along the
negotiations were there were still major
obstacles the truth is that the Saudi
demands prove to be a real challenge for
the survival of the negotiations
themselves for instance the Arab regime
demanded among other things that the
United States commit itself to the full
defense of its entire territory on on
top of that it did not give up its
desire to develop its civilian nuclear
infrastructure with American help and
not surprisingly in close contact with
the Palestinian Authority it demanded
that Israel put a stop to the
colonization of the West Bank and
withdraw from the territory Washington
for its part pressured riat to increase
its crude oil production among other
things in other words on the table was
not only the agreement with Israel but
also the large scale reissue of the US
Saudi defense pact and a new energy
policy we are not therefore talking
about an agreement that was
straightforward to reach nevertheless
despite all the discrepancies
negotiations continued all three
countries knew that they stood to gain a
great deal from this agreement the
United States could counterbalance the
growing influence of China in the Middle
East Israel could take a giant step
towards ending the historic Arab Israeli
tension and Riyad could stabilize the
region enjoying us protection and a
powerful New Economic and technological
partner Israel thus despite all the
discrepancies the negotiations finally
seemed to be going full steam ahead
however on the 7th of October came the
brutal Hamas attack and days later
everything went down the drain Saudi
Arabia pauses normalization talks with
Israel amid ongoing war with Hamas in
fact the Biden Administration claimed
that Hamas attacked Israel precisely to
break off negotiations between the three
countries one of the reasons why they
acted like they did why Hamas moved on
Israel is because they knew I was about
to sit down with the Saudis because the
Saudis wanted to recognize Israel and
that would in fact unite the Middle East
be that as it may the reality is that
the Hamas attack has disrupted all plans
Saudi Arabia is now juggling its options
to avoid blowing up all its options
listen
up balancing the
scales the Hamas attacks provoked a
political earthquake at the
international level with countries
aligning themselves with one side or the
other surely the opinions of Western
countries along with China and Russia
are the ones you will remember most but
of course the Arab countries also took a
stand for example Bahrain and the United
Arab Emirates Israel's Partners since
the Abraham Accords condemned the Hamas
attack Qatar for its part condemned
Israel for its constant pressure on the
Gaza Strip and the West Bank but what
about Saudi Arabia well unlike in
previous cases it did not have the
luxury of choosing between black and
white so it chose to play with the gray
while calling for a lasting ceasefire
and the promotion of the two-state
solution it has condemned both the Hamas
attack and Israel's actions in Gaza and
the West Bank and you may be wondering
but wasn't it Hamas that has ruined the
economic plans of the Saudis well yes
indeed but this is not enough to
position itself clearly in Israel's
favor keep in mind that the Palestinian
cause remains a particularly sensitive
issue within the Arab and Muslim commun
community and Saudi Society is certainly
no exception a very different thing
however is the level of sympathy in
Saudi Arabia for Hamas which is at Rock
Bottom in fact while in 2014 48% of
Saudis had a positive view of Hamas this
year only 10% held that perception this
trend not only mirrors the United Arab
Emirates but also the feeling among
gaza's own population which
overwhelmingly prefers the strip to be
administered by the Palestinian
Authority be that as it may hamas's loss
of popularity among the Saudi is hardly
surprising after all since the creation
of the Palestinian group in the 1980s
Saudi Arabia had strong reticence and
distanced itself from this group keep in
mind that Hamas emerged as a branch of
the Muslim Brotherhood and of course we
cannot forget that the Saudi monarchy
condemned and still condemns the Muslim
Brotherhood because they consider them a
threat to its own Survival nevertheless
the relationship existed in fact unlike
Washington Riyad did recognize the
Electoral victory of Hamas in the Gaza
Strip in 2006 however from 2012 onwards
this relationship of mere cordiality
ended up going all the Arab Springs had
put many Arab governments in check so
the Saudi Royal House understood that it
could not afford any missteps for
example they supported a coup to remove
Muhammad Mory in Egypt Mory was a member
of the Muslim Brotherhood and a leader
relatively close to Hamas since then
relations between Riyad and Gaza have
gone from bad to worse to the point that
Saudi police have arrested Hamas members
in the country yet in the last 2 years
Saudi Arabia and Hamas have been moving
closer together again why basically
because Riyad knew that for the signing
of the agreement with Israel to go ahead
it was essential to find a political
solution in Palestine and of course the
tension with Hamas was a major stumbling
block for this reason the Saudi regime
released Hamas prisoners and also
allowed its leaders to make the
pilgrimage to Mecca from Qatar but in
spite of everything Riyad has always
been clear Hamas is a hindrance now is
it only because it hurts their economic
plans or is there more to it well listen
up Iran controlling the
[Music]
game if you are a loyal follower of
visual politic you will already know
that Saudi Arabia has a particularly
awkward neighbor with whom it has had
several run-ins katar since the arrival
of imir Alani in 1995 Saudi Arabia has
had a tense relationship with this small
Arab country whether for providing
coverage of the Arab Spring through the
AL jazer Channel or for allegedly
encouraging islamist terrorism in the
region Saudi Arabia and Qatar have been
far from good friends in fact between
2017 and 2021 Saudi Arabia and many
other countries such as Bahrain United
Arab Emirates and Jordan imposed a
Savage blockade on Qatar a blockade that
by the way as we already told you was a
huge failure now the tension can flare
up again because Qatar has once again
shown its support for Hamas nor is it
unusual Qatar has been harboring
officials and former senior officials of
the Palestinian group such as khed
Michel for more than a decade what more
Doha has so far failed to condemn the
terrorist attack which not surprisingly
has reinforced both the accusations that
it is a promoter of terrorism and the
idea that Qatar has a strong interest in
the survival of Hamas this time however
Doha has not been able to be overly
belligerent Washington which has a large
military base in the country would not
have allowed it and that explains
precisely this important news item Hamas
leaders leave Qatar for unknown
destination be that as it may Qatar is
not Saudi Arabia's main concern at the
moment Iran
is okay you might think that tensions
between the two countries have
disappeared after new stories like these
China Chinese broker deal upends mid
East diplomacy and challenges us the
agreement negotiated in Beijing to
restore relations between Saudi Arabia
and Iran signaled at least a temporary
reordering of the usual alliances and
rivalries with Washington left on the
sidelines however nothing could be
further from the truth Iran and Saudi
Arabia remain great Regional Rivals two
giants that seek to dominate the Middle
East and that do not trust each other
and it is here that Iran has an asset
that Riyad would love to have its
non-state armies we've already told you
about them on this channel not long ago
Hezbollah is Iran's Main and most
powerful non-state Ally and as you may
remember Hamas has also received huge
amounts of money and weapons from Iran
and Hezbollah yet Tran has another Ally
that usually goes unnoticed an ally that
is on Saudi Arabia's doorstep in Yemen
we are talking of course about the
houthis organized in the 1990s as a
political group seeking to channel the
demands of the country's zedi Muslims
they became more radical over time they
even started several armed clashes
between 2004 and 2010 against the
government of the dictator Ali Abdullah
Sal whom they accused of corruption and
of being under the orders of Saudi
Arabia in 2011 the hoodies played an
important role in the country's
Revolution that ended with the overthrow
of Salah and the coming to power of
Manser al-hadi but it was not until 2014
that the hoodies gained real power in
Yemen in September of the same year they
took sa the capital of the country Yemen
was then plunged into a civil war that
lasts to this day and in which Saudi
troops have intervened directly to
ensure the functioning of the bab El
mandb Strait a crucial zone for the
international transport of hydrocarbons
however Saudi Arabia's intervention also
led to another key factor guess what it
is 3 2 1 that's right Iranian Aid to the
hoodies in fact since 2011 new stories
like this have been the order of the day
US Navy says it seized weapons from Iran
likely Bound for houthis in Yemen US
Navy seizes 70 tons of Iranian missile
fuel from sailboat to Yemen US military
says huge Iranian weapons shipment
destined for Yemen Rebels seized in Gulf
of Oman Saudi Arabia and the hthis have
been clashing militarily since 2015 it's
a war that has left more than 400,000
people dead and 80% of Yemen's
population plunged into a severe
humanitarian
[Music]
crisis conflict is no longer as bloody
as it was in the early years and a
temporary ceasefire has even been
achieved nevertheless the conflict
between Israel and Hamas may change
everything again news like this is a
good reflection of this major threat
Iran looks to houy proxies to escalate
fight with Israel the Iranian backed
militia in Yemen has launched drone and
missile attacks on Israeli and American
targets americ American officials fear
the group could go too far and incite a
wider War houie militia threatens to
block All Ships headed to Israel visual
politic Community the war could return
to Yemen and that could drag Riyad back
keep in mind that a houi victory could
mean the beginning of other Shiite
uprisings in the Middle East even in
Saudi Arabia itself a country where the
Shiite Community is located precisely in
the territories with the greatest oil
activity let alone if Israel were to
intervene militarily when the time comes
that would leave re between a rock and a
hard place Israel ready to act against
Hoy Rebels if International Community
fails to do so National Security adviser
says so you see all indications are that
Saudi Arabia is actually hoping for a
quick Israeli victory over Hamas a
victory that will once and for all end
the headache of this Palestinian group
reduce Iran's influence in the region
and serve as a deterrent to other groups
but at this point the question is now
over to you do you think that Saudi
Arabia will openly support Israel
despite everything that has happened
will we see an agreement between Israel
and Saudi Arabia soon you can leave me
your answers in the comments and as
always don't forget that here on visual
politic we release new videos every week
so subscribe to this Channel and hit the
little bell so you don't miss any of our
updates if you like the video go ahead
and like it and I will be seeing you in
the next one all the best see you very
[Music]
soon